this is the soundcore motion x600 by
Anker and it is a phenomenal portable
speaker and I'm absolutely Blown Away
how they're able to sell such an amazing
device for the price that they are
charging especially for three different
reasons now I have owned many speakers
by anchor this one I absolutely loved so
much so that I bought a second one and
when anchor reached out to sponsor a
video and showcase this new product I
said absolutely because I think they
provide some of the best bang for the
buck value out there and now not only
best bang for the buck but best for very
little bucks now I've owned the motion
Boom for a few years now and they have
been amazing I could take it anywhere
with me but they did have
downside the soundcore motion x600 fixes
those issues in one ups that and pretty
much every single way now the craziest
selling point that I was a little bit
skeptical of was their spatial audio
tuning but when I heard it I was just
shocked I've been using spatial audio
for a while now and when Apple launched
their version originally I wasn't very
impressed because it made a lot of
sounds sound actually worse now sound
core spatial audio they self-develop and
it could turn any stereo sound into
spatial and because my previous
experience I thought it wouldn't be that
great but it works phenomenally this
thing has three separate amplifiers and
five speakers built into it including
this up firing one and they are very
powerful and the algorithm that they are
using works great go ahead and take a
listen to the difference yourself with
spatial audio off and then on
foreign
[Music]
now I have some very expensive
microphones but the difference you heard
isn't even as a big of a difference as
what you hear in real life so with the
spatial audio button up top I just keep
that turned on all the time because it
works so well now this thing is also
certified for wireless hi-res audio with
the Kodak that is three times your
standard Bluetooth so you can get much
higher quality into the speaker to work
for that spatial audio now if you're
using a device that can't support
high-res audio do not worry because that
sound test you just heard that was with
an iPhone and even with AAC it sounds
fantastic now this speaker also outputs
50 RMS watts of power even if you have
it unplugged whereas a lot of the
competitors if you don't have it plugged
into the wall it gets a lot quieter
which it really really sucks so I'm very
glad right about that now on the back we
have a flap that seals it in for
waterproofing and in there we have a USB
type-c port for power which is great I'm
glad it's not micro USB like some of the
competitors and it also has an AUX input
which is great and what some of the
competitors do not include now I've been
using this thing everywhere inside of
the house bringing it downstairs with
this handle bringing it outside and even
bringing it to the hot tub because this
is ipx7 rated for water resistance so
you do not have to worry and that is
sweet it also gets very loud and unlike
some other speakers you don't get
Distortion when you crank up that volume
now another thing that I like is that we
have this base up button right here
typically I keep that on but if I'm
listening to it like at night for
example at the hot tub I will just press
that button it cuts down on the base
which means that you're not going to be
disturbing your neighbors now we also
have the Bluetooth pairing button the on
button and some controls up top now the
other thing that really impresses me is
the build quality and materials this
handle up here is metal it is insanely
sturdy feels really nice and the same
thing with the front here that has this
really nice pattern the top over here
for the up firing speaker and even the
back they did not cheap out and this
makes it feel very very premium and also
durable which is really nice now as far
as actual sound quality compared to
other speakers well even with this one I
got rid of my other Bluetooth speakers
because it sounded so good and I did
have to do some tuning here as far as
the EQ and I'll show you guys the app in
just a little bit but this thing sounds
fantastic even straight out of the gate
and because of the Five drivers that we
have in here and uh the spatial audio as
well as the quality going up to forty
thousand Hertz the highs are so so clear
and especially if you're using high-res
audio it kicks it up another notch the
clarity you get is simply unmatched from
speakers that even cost double or close
to Triple the price and as far as uh
what they're competing against in terms
of the drivers the design the spatial
audio those are speakers that are five
to ten times more expensive now what I
would kind of compare it to that I have
would be the new home pod that can also
do spatial audio and has awareness and
I'll show you guys a sample of that but
that thing costs 300 bucks which is
about double compared to their
discounted price for this and the anchor
is great at doing discounts
um and it is not portable and it is not
waterproof and you cannot just connect
to it with Bluetooth so you can't just
take it somewhere so the value that you
get here is incredible and go ahead and
take a listen to the comparison between
the sounds
is painkillers
[Music]
getting this thing I mean it is a
no-brainer in my opinion and sitting
around and listening to it with a
variety of different tracks from hip-hop
tracks to pop tracks to classical tracks
The Sound Stage that you get from this
especially when you uh turn on the
spatialized audio it is just great so it
takes regular songs that don't have a
good Sound Stage good mixing makes it
sound way better and songs that do have
a very wide kind of sound it just takes
it to a whole nother level and its
built-in battery will last for up to 12
hours so you can use this thing all day
have incredible sound not worry about
any water or moisture and overall I
think it's one of the best values or
even the best value if you care about
sound quality and you want a portable
speaker now I also want to show you guys
the sound core app so here I have some
of my devices I'm going to press on the
motion x600 I could see the battery life
there I can control the volume and then
we can go into the equalizer so the cool
thing is they give you a lot of control
now here is their signature sound
profile like I mentioned with the motion
boom I had to tweak that quite a bit for
my liking but this one sounds awesome
right at the gate now here's the base of
button so if you toggle that off you see
that drops down quite a bit it looks a
little dramatic here in reality you
still have Bass But it cuts down nicely
so you don't annoy your neighbors or you
don't wake up your family especially at
night now they also have a few different
presets here for voice there's a balance
one and they can go into custom now I
have a few created and I have flat I
have my own night mode here or you can
just go into custom here and have some
settings and they actually allow you to
go to a full band where you can tweak
all of this and then bringing up this
last one you can go all the way super
high here to I think it's the 28 000
Hertz so you have a lot of flexibility
to tune it exactly how you like it and
then we can actually go back here go
into our settings and then this is beta
former right here but you can turn off
the voice prompt you can change your
auto power off so that if you don't have
a signal you're gonna save battery life
and you can also update the firmware as
well so go ahead and use the links down
below to check it out get yourself a
killer deal right at its launch point
and I know you will absolutely love this
speaker go ahead and click that Circle
above to subscribe check out one of
those videos right over there this has
been Max and I will see you in the next
one
[Music]